>> Sean: IN OTHER NEWS
TONIGHT, THERE WERE REPORTS THAT
TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM HAS BEEN
PREPARING TO HAND OVER WRITTEN
ANSWERS TO MUELLER'S TEAM.
JOINING US NOW LIVE FROM
WASHINGTON ON THIS AND MUCH
MORE, FOX NEWS CHIEF
INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT, OUR
OWN CATHERINE HERRIDGE.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE WE MIGHT BE
GETTING TO THE END.
TWO SOURCES FAMILIAR WITH THE
DISCUSSIONS TOLD FOX TONIGHT
THAT THE WRITTEN ANSWERS ARE
BEING FINALIZED AND COULD BE
SUBMITTED TO THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MOELLER AND HIS TEAM.
THEY REPORTED THE PRESIDENT'S
LEGAL TEAM WAS PREPARING WRITTEN
RESPONSE ABOUT ALLEGED
COORDINATION WITH RUSSIA DURING
THE 2016 CAMPAIGN ACCOUNT AND
NOT OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE OVER
THE PRESIDENT'S MAY 2017 FIRING
OF FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY.
AND REPORTING TO CAPITOL HILL,
DEMOCRATS ALSO RAMPED UP ATTACKS
ON MATTHEW WHITAKER.
WITH THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE'S RANKING DEMOCRAT
DIANNE FEINSTEIN CALLING FOR
EMERGENCY HEARINGS WITH WHITAKER
AND ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS.
AND THAT WAS ACCORDING TO ETHICS
REVIEWS.
>> THAT'S GOING TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
>> AS LONG AS HE MADE THEM A
PRIVATE CITIZEN, NO.
THE LEGAL COUNSEL PLANS TO ISSUE
AN OPINION DEFENDING THE
WHITAKER APPOINTMENT AND PUSHING
BACK STRONGLY AGAINST A LEGAL
ANALYSIS AND THE APPOINTMENT IS